Ну що друзі Кінець епохи кумавства
настав Вітаю всіх вас Дивіться якщо в
житті так сталося що ви є сусідами
родини зеленських то вас далі в житті
буде все добре От питають мене Чому саме
піщанська чому вона я скажу вам Ну
напевно Може ви б стали президентом ви б
своїх сусідів призначали а став
Володимир Олександрович Він призначає
своїх До речі з нами є сьогодні Ольга
піщанська Може вона в своєму виступі
пояснить Це дуже цікаво дивіться її
сестра Світлана піщанська директорка
фірми на яку оформлена Віла родини
зеленських в Італії Ну я все розумію ну
ви вже були головою антимонопольного
комітету тепер голова рахункової палати
ну незамінна людина ну Може все-таки
пошукати серед інших сусідів Ну не можеш
впертися в одну сусідку в одну родину це
якось Мені здається навіть І незрозуміло
інші сусіди можуть і образитись